[Music]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen a warm welcome to
our official awards ceremony 2023.
since many years the fiber to the home
Council Europe has been handing out
three Awards the individual award the
operator award and the Charles cow award
they reward people and organizations for
their outstanding contributions to the
well-being of the fiber industry and the
acceleration of ftth deployment all over
Europe
the winners of these awards are chosen
and ratified by the board of the ftth
council Europe and the committee chairs
now this year we announced first of all
an additional and a new award
which is the champion of diversity award
recognizing the undoubtable efforts made
by a company to address the diversity
issue within the fiber industry
the women in fiber committee within the
council has taken the lead and analyzed
companies on various diversity
initiatives
there were three finalists
that was calling
there was fiber host
and there was prismian
and the winner is
fiber host because of their excellence
in gender mix effectiveness at ensuring
training for female staff
greatest percentage of women in senior
positions an excellent maternity and
parental leave provision
now can I ask Martha voice CEO of fiber
host to join us and accept our first
champion of diversity award
[Applause]
[Music]
s
you can read the microphone and have a
few words thank you thank you very much
Eric I will just quickly give you some
numbers
92 percent of people working in our
company
sees equal development opportunities for
male and female
over 80 percent of our people feels that
they can express freely their opinion
with no fear of consequences
forty percent of our staff are women
and 35 percent of us are managers
so this shows that D and I matters are
very important in fiber house and I'm
really glad that all our efforts were
noticed
and I'm extremely proud that we are the
first ever operator winning the winning
this Championship champion of diversity
award
I'm really honored and I can assure you
that this is not the end of our
promotion and spreading the dni in fiber
host and in uh in Poland and further on
and special thanks to my team to my
co-workers who are involved in this
involved in this matter guys you are
doing really a great job thank you very
much
City
the operator Awards acknowledges an
operator company that has significantly
contributed to the development and
rollout of ftth in Europe
also here three finalists
fibrous from UK
Cyro from Ireland
and open reach from UK
and the winner is
open reach
in the recent years open reached the
fixed access infrastructure arm of BT
has committed an invested to increase
and accelerate its total fttp build from
20 million to 25 million premises by
December 2026. and they have already
passed more than 10 million homes so far
so can I ask trevolini Network
Technology director for Opa reach to
join us and accept our operator award
please
[Music]
congratulations thank you
right well thank you Eric
our build alongside that of others in
the UK is improving people's lives
and creates new economic opportunities
you know today
um over 3 million homes are already
benefiting from Ultra fast
and Ultra reliable Broadband from us and
we are super excited to see the future
that full fiber will create for
everybody in the UK so it's my absolute
pleasure to say thank you and to accept
this award from ftth Council on behalf
of openreach thank you very much
please be secret
the individual award honors a single
person for their unique efforts to make
fdth happen in Europe
there were three finalists Mr Peter
dimov director fixed Access Network at
vivacom Bulgaria
founder of objective fever within
prismian
and Mrs Garza mapelink senior expert
politique on favalton Deutsche glass
father
and the winner is
Mrs Garza mapelink
since joining Deutsche class father in
2011 Gerda has tirelessly advocated for
acceptance of modern fiber deployment
techniques in Germany on local or
Regional level as well as on the federal
level
since 2020 ghetto has been a central
part of the telecoms group in the din
standardization committee tasked with
developing standards for modern
deployment
geta's drive and energy has secured a
huge lever for accelerating fiber across
all Telecom operators
can I ask Gerda to join us and accept
our individual award please
[Applause]
[Music]
please congratulations
well ladies and gentlemen I never ever
expected that someone was watching me on
my sometimes unusual way to make fdth
happen
in my opinion success depends on
teamwork if you are a lucky one there's
a great team on your side
I am such a lucky one
so I would like to thank my dear
colleagues who have given me fantastic
support
together we put fiber to the home on the
agenda at all levels of politics and
government
and today I'm very proud to say that
dodging glass father has connected more
than well over a million homes
but
um
I think the driver for full fiber
coverage
is my topic number one
innovative
and intelligent Construction
fiber construction should have its own
legal standards
I look forward to our success with this
important
and my absolute favorite topic thank you
very much for the individual award
thank you
and last but not least
the Charles cow award honors an
individual who has made an outstanding
lifelong achievement
and contribution to the promotion and
deployment of full fiber connectivity
we have two finalists
Mr Heinz babish vice president of CMG
and Dr Marion Edwards director of
technology and program management office
at Corning
and the winner is
Heinz babish
Heinz can be named a grand senior of the
European fiber
and a true Open Access fiber rollout
evangelist
whilst others might sit in their
backyard and enjoy their retirement
Heinz never decreased his engagement and
passion for fiber Networks
he is active as ftth expert organizer
panelist and moderator in countless
events and seminars and made the
the Action Group gigabit hybrid access
within CMG profiting for many years and
a good platform professional platform
for yours for the Austrian fiber
community
it's profiting for many years of his
knowledge and personal engagement
now what characterizes Heinz the most is
the following
if you need support for any fiber
related issue from him
you can be sure about his commitment
even before he answers the call
so can I ask Heinz to join us and accept
our Charles cow award
thank you
[Music]
please congratulations thank you
Eric I thank you very much I'm
overwhelmed and what I have to say is
now when we started in Alcatel in 1900
and 188 there was a pick
study of a very famous Consulting Group
and they said well now since packet
switching is there and Broadway is
coming
we need to every
household and to every company
immediately a fiber
but you know as it is with predictions
something maybe the the development is
going another way because the next 20
years it happened nearly nothing and
then I was a child already and we I
started we started what am I doing in
addition in our account in our
association at CMG and a good friend of
me I was an expert
told us well we should focus on Fiverr
because it's very important and Austria
is very behind so what we are doing so
we made the study trip to Sweden we
learned a lot and when we came back say
well now we have to do something we we
found a group we found a group we work a
working group
and who will but who will make it well
and I said yes I I'm doing this and this
started in 2008 and then we did a lot of
things we first have said what we aren't
really doing well we said well we have
two positions first is ftth is the most
important thing which should happen in
the infrastructure area infrastructure
is a main thing and the infrastructure
for telecommunication is now getting
even more important since fiber has to
come and it must be ubiquitous it must
go everywhere and the next thing was but
it can be supported by an alternative
business model and this always decided
we should convince everybody that the
Open netback Access model is very
important and then we said well we have
to Define exactly what we mean it must
be in wholesale only model and now we
can say we have been
in Austria successful with both things
nobody really is doubting on Fiverr and
in Austria the Open Access models are
taking doing and they're very very very
successful but of course it's not yet
over a lot of problems stand before us
so anyway we'll see what we try to do
something more and I thank you you all
for this award it motivates a lot
absolutely absolutely absolutely
they want to sit here
I I told you that Heinz can do a bundle
on its own so no worries about that so
can I ask uh to make a picture so if we
stand with the trophies here at the
middle then we make a picture of the
awards that would be nice
[Applause]
[Music]